los jóvenes del liverpool volvieron a la
pista de baile este viernes y sin
restricciones el festival de música
servirá como ensayo con miras a la
reactivación de eventos masivos una
prueba apoyada directamente desde el
gobierno y que los jóvenes han recibido
con los brazos abiertos todos nosotros
estamos emocionados estamos todos al
borde de las lágrimas listos para entrar
sinceramente aún no estamos borrachos
así que estamos preparados estén ahora
este gran aplauso para liverpool por
celebrar el primer evento sin
distanciamiento social nos encanta esta
ciudad nos encanta este el evento se
extenderá el sábado y reunirá a 6 mil
asistentes entre los dos días todos de
entre 18 y 20 años para acceder al
primer festival de este tipo en 14 meses
la audiencia debe presentar una pcr
negativa al respecto la alcaldía de la
ciudad recordó a los participantes
mantener las medidas de seguridad una
vez concluida la fiesta
si te vas del primer baile the circus
music esta noche por favor recuerda que
las medidas de seguridad vuelven a
entrar en vigor cuando se abandona el
lugar
si tienes basura tirada en los
contenedores previstos esperamos que
hayas tenido una gran noche gracias por
participar esta prueba piloto está
dentro de la reapertura que planea reino
unido- con dos tercios de la población
con al menos una dosis de la vacuna
planea habilitar el acceso al interior
de bares y restaurantes el 17 de mayo y
suprimir casi todas las restricciones
para el 21 de junio